con el tradicional indulto al pavo
donald trump inicio las festividades
anuales del día de acción de gracias al
tiempo que los estadounidenses empezaron
a viajar en masa para pasar la
festividad con sus familias sólo vine a
casa a ver a mi familia a mi chica de
nuevo
creo que las fiestas y todos son muy
importantes ahora especialmente porque
la gente está agotada por la pandemia
de acuerdo con la administración de
seguridad del transporte el número de
estadounidenses que viajan se ha
incrementado en la última semana y más
de 4 millones se subieron a un avión
desde el viernes pero aunque sólo
representa el 40% del mismo período de
hace un año
el repunte muestra que mucha gente está
ignorando los llamados de las
autoridades sanitarias a no viajar y
evitar las grandes reuniones familiares
sé que duele no hacerlo porque es una
hermosa tradición y temporada
pero sigamos adelante porque en el
futuro podrán hacerlo es un sacrificio
qué pasará
eeuu tiene más de 12 millones de casos
de qom y 19 y más de un cuarto de millón
de personas han perdido la vida por la
enfermedad
los números han subido en los últimos
días con más de 3 millones de nuevos
casos registrados desde el inicio de
noviembre